[Music]
we all have many decisions to make some
are easy and straightforward while
others can be tricky in terms of
appropriateness effectiveness and ethics
today i look forward to digging in and
exploring ethics in our personal and
professional lives i'm matt abrahams and
i teach strategic communication at
stanford graduate school of business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast
i am super excited to be joined by neil
maholtra and ken schatz neil is the
edith m cornell professor of political
economy at the gsb he also serves as the
director of the center for social
innovation
ken is the david s and ann m barlow
professor of political economy also at
the gsb
together neil and ken teach a core
course on business ethics and recently
they published a new book together
called leading with values strategies
for making ethical decisions in business
and life
thanks for being here thank you matt so
great to be here thanks so much man all
right let's get going
neil you and ken teach business ethics
can you share with us how you two think
about ethics and the role they play or
should play in business sure that's a
great question i would say that the
concept of the role in business and
society has changed a lot in the last 30
years and it's going through a sea
change as we speak and i think that
probably wouldn't be new to your
audience given all of the social issues
that businesses are involved in and i
would say in the 1980s there was a big
emphasis on shareholder value that the
primary ethical and moral responsibility
of a business was to maximize value for
its shareholders for the owners of the
company and i think kind of increasingly
we've moved to more of a stakeholder
model where businesses have to be aware
of various stakeholder groups in society
and this is what kind of motivated us to
write the book which is how do you
actually rigorously and analytically
think about your role as a business
leader given all of these new challenges
and responsibilities you might have
where various groups sort of demand that
businesses act ethically and we draw in
a lot of intellectual traditions ranging
from psychology to normative philosophy
to economics political science and kind
of gather all those insights so the
readers can have really tangible
actionable recommendations on how to
lead organizations in the challenging
environment we currently face i really
appreciate it in your book how you did
that will you draw on all these
different ways of thinking and ways of
studying this and then the very specific
advice and guidance you give is is very
helpful and i love that you have some
activities for people to think through
and i can see how it would help our
students as they prepare to enter the
business world and act ethically can you
write that effective leaders not only
know their values but can manage the
diversity of values within their
organizations
how do you recommend that people
identify their core values and determine
those of others on their team or in
their company
i think the first thing i would say is
what not to do is to look at the
company's
public statements of its mission and
values i think
some companies those are very authentic
to what the company is about and what
motivates people within the company but
when i look at those statements there's
often a lot of similarity across
companies in those statements and i
don't think that really reflects the the
differences across companies and amongst
individuals within companies so i would
say the first thing this requires and
this is implicit in the idea of managing
a diversity of values but i think it's a
mistake that some leaders make is to
don't assume that the people in your
organization share your own values
some of the time they do some of the
time they don't some of the times some
of them do but there's a bunch who don't
and those are the most difficult sorts
of situations we have this exercise
actually the concluding chapter of the
book
is to have in which we do in our in our
mba class is to have people sit down and
think and write up their own core values
and drawing on stuff from the book but
also religious traditions cultural
traditions personal history often really
plays an important role in driving
people's own values and i think as a
leader that's something that one can do
for oneself one can also you can imagine
doing this with it is a team exercise
but the problem with that is some of the
time people feel they have to present
themselves a certain way
in the work context and things like that
so it can be really tricky to
figure out the points where
you know disagree with himself and i
think that's why one of our big
important takeaways from the book is
like well set up organizations allow for
dissent and disagreement about values
and to make it possible feasible and
encouraged for people to do that
that can mean living with some conflict
that can be uncomfortable for people i
really appreciate that that last point
about how it can be uncomfortable but it
allows for a more
free
organization where people can share
their different opinions we have on a
number of occasions on this podcast
talked about the notion of psychological
safety about self-reflection on your
position and your attitudes and to that
you add this list of values and i think
that's really important and taking the
time to just reflect on your values and
write them down i think can be very
helpful and and finding ways to
encourage your colleagues and others can
also help you set up an environment
where people really can feel that it's
okay to share their point of view and to
disagree with others so thank you for
that neil you and ken make the case that
our values lead to the moral choices we
make and motivate the actions we take
what thoughts do you have about how we
can assess our actions in your book you
discuss different tests people can use
and deploy yeah so this kind of ties to
something i think you mentioned earlier
which is kind of one thing we try to do
in the book is take abstract concepts
and convert them into tangible tests and
evaluate them so we have one chapter
where we talk about where organizations
and leaders can maybe go on the wrong
path right and so we kind of lay out
various tests that can prevent people
from veering in the wrong decision
that are inconsistent with their values
for example we talk about bright line
rules this is an approach many people
take an example we give is clayton
christensen the famous management
scholar who uh passed away a few years
ago you know he had a a mormon
upbringing with the lds and a big you
know he had these bright line rules for
example that he was going to use sunday
as a day of rest and he tells an
anecdote about how he cost his
basketball team the championship because
he didn't play on that day but the whole
point he's trying to say is is that
if you violate your brightline rules
then those rules become meaningless so
as we kind of discussed that's a really
valuable and very clear way to design a
test but there's many situations in a
complex business environment where you
can't predict exactly what's going to
happen so there's not going to be
brightline rules you can list in advance
so then we talked about other tests so i
think a very common one business leaders
talk about is the new york times test or
the wall street journal test
which is
always think you know if the new york
times was writing about what you did uh
you know would you do the same thing and
as we explain there's some flaws with
this test and one of the flaws is is
that the new york times doesn't really
write about very much stuff that's going
on in the world so most of the decisions
we face are not theranose level
decisions they are
you know there are things that the media
are not going to cover but actually have
a lot of implications on organizations
how we lead and how people perceive our
leadership so we talk about actually a
third test which is the friends and
family test you know would you be
comfortable telling your friends and
family about your actions and decisions
or are you actually hiding things from
your friends and family and this is
actually something that's very practical
and realistic because it comes up all
the time you're really not going to be
on the phone with a new york times
reporter but you will be talking to your
spouse or your loved ones at night and
telling them how your day went and i
think it's actually a very telling test
where you're
withholding information because you
think that there's inconsistent with
your value structure now we talk about
limitations of that test too for example
sometimes our friends and family aid in
a bed
us but nonetheless i think we try to
kind of explain different tests and the
strengths and limitations of each of
them so i i was smiling as you were
talking about the friends and family
test because uh with my two teenage boys
we have what we call the grandma test
what would you think if grandma found
out about what you said or did and that
resonated with me it sounds to me though
that thinking through how you will
assess or test your actions is really
important to do and to have a shared
agreement not just with yourself but
others on your team would also help so i
encourage everybody to think about how
will you assess those decisions and
actions that you you take
can you talk about how situational
social environments and norms can also
influence our moral actions
what best practices can you suggest to
help us not only understand these
external influences but work to align
them with our values
so i like how you phrase that matt that
it's not just about it's not treating
this external situation is something
that's just kind of fixed and i gotta
live with but recognizing that the
situations we put ourselves into
are a choice and actually that's often
the most important choice we make that's
gonna determine what we do so i think
there's this tendency
in western cultures specifically
especially and you know the american
west and silicon valley to you know
valorize the heroic individual and you
know the thing is with the psychologists
have shown you know i'm actually not a
psychologist karma political economy
scholar but i look at what the the
lessons of social psychology they've
shown pretty well that we are not heroic
individuals we just aren't um it'd be
great if we were but you know we aren't
i mean a good thing though is that we
are capable of being great if we put
ourselves in those in the right
situation so i think the first lesson is
not assuming i will do the right thing
no matter the circumstances i think
planning ahead for thinking like the
circumstances that i put myself into
will shape what i will do and may even
shape the person i become
and i think this is one of the most
important
lessons and things that for people to
think about when you know thinking about
jobs to take or lines of professions to
go into you know all sorts of career
planning things is like i'm going to be
part of this organization in this
situation do i want to be like the
people in this organization is that what
i aspire to for myself and i think
that's a really foundational like
planning thing
and then the other part of this is no
matter what situations we put ourselves
into some of the time stuff is going to
come up that pushes us to do things in
ways that are out of step with our
values and i think the the biggest
lesson there is to just try to
find a way to get oneself
out of the situation i mean literally
physically
so you're not in that i mean immediate
physical context has a lot of effect on
us but also like emotionally and this
sort of goes back to the friends and
family test i think it's good to
you know balance things off of those who
were close to those who we trust those
who we trust to be willing to criticize
us
because they value us and they love us i
think that's a really
important thing so i think that's kind
of a long-winded answer but i think the
question you asked is probably more
important than the answer i gave that
question was primed by a discussion we
had on a previous podcast episode where
i interviewed philip zimbardo one of the
most famous social psychologist who has
dedicated a lot of his career to
studying how the situation influences
people so that was fresh in my mind as i
was reading that chapter of your book
the the other thing you mentioned ken
that i think is really critical is that
you have to have trusted others that
that can give you good clear honest
feedback and that can be hard sometimes
in a business setting because people
don't want to offend or they they're
afraid that there might be political or
hierarchical ramifications so so that's
important to find those trusted others
i love that you two dedicate time in
your business ethics class and in your
book to discuss strategies for
communication i had a big smile on my
face as i was reading that neil can you
share the pointers you provide around
understanding both your audience and
yourself and framing messages to align
morally sure and this is kind of ties to
what you just said people are oftentimes
worried in these polarized times
that there's just a lot of disagreement
conflict um it's hard to reach
resolution so in the book we try to
bridge literature on moral philosophy
with communication strategies
and specifically we're very influenced
by what's called moral foundations
theory which is the argument that
everybody has sort of these deep-seated
moral intuitions and foundations which
drive how they see the world their kind
of senses just like we have touch and
taste um we have kind of moral senses
that guide how we see it and once you
realize this you realize that you know
when we disagree with someone it's
oftentimes that they are coming and
using a different moral sense than we
are um so an example is you know like
debates over coveted lockdowns in the
workplace or vaccine mandates you know
some people the moral sense they really
are attuned to is harm so anything they
can do to reduce harm to other people
would be great other people are
motivated by a moral sense of liberty
which is that people should have the
freedom to do what they want and kind of
restricting their freedom is a negative
thing so if for example you want to
implement like a tough covenant policy
whether it's like a vaccine mandate or
something like that and you come from
the harm perspective it's a really
ineffective strategy to convince people
from the liberty perspective using
language and argument centered around
harm so that's telling a story how
you've been told it not looking from
their perspectives and the stories they
tell the most effective thing you can do
is to understand the other person's
story and frame the language and
arguments around them so to argue that
hey if you really care about liberty we
actually need these vaccines because
this will open up a flourishing economy
that will allow us to do everything we
want and i think kind of this is what
framing is about is fundamentally about
being empathetic and you know there's
been a lot of research done on
perspective taking and how to change
people's minds the results are just very
clear which is the the worst thing you
can do is show up to someone's house and
explain to them why they're morally
wrong
that tends to not work very well whereas
you know when they've tried to change
people's minds on gay marriage or
transgender rights they start by
listening by saying well tell me a story
of when you felt discriminated against
or you felt excluded and then they get
people talking about themselves and they
say well you know this is what happened
to this other person and they felt a lot
like you did
and so coming at it from a
non-judgmental view listening rather
than lecturing uh tends to be most
effective i yeah you took me back to our
thanksgiving table where where we had
lots of people being told that they were
morally wrong
so i i appreciate that this notion of
moral sense is really valuable we we
talk a lot about understanding your
audience taking their perspective
empathy
moral sense is yet another one of the
things to consider when we talk about
attitudes resistance points but also
somebody's moral perspective and how you
can adjust and adapt your messages so
it's not just that you have to
appreciate it you then have to frame
your message in alignment with
somebody's moral sense and thank you for
that that's the and the examples you
used were very helpful in explaining
that
before we end i'd like to ask you the
same three questions i ask everyone who
joins me are you gentlemen up for that
sure of course yeah i guess we can't
duck it if you ask everyone that's true
you would definitely stand out so so ken
we're going to start with you if you
were to capture the best communication
advice you have ever received as a five
to seven word presentation slide title
what would that be
your audience is not yourself
and
to really internalize that when
communicating i think it's hard because
we naturally kind of talk to
ourselves and
play up things that we believe it i like
how you captured it i often say in my
strategic communication classes that the
biggest mistake people make is we start
from the wrong place we start from
saying here is what i want to say and
that puts us in on the wrong path your
title of your slide really emphasizes
that thank you
now for both of you i'd like you to
answer who is a communicator that you
admire and why and neil why don't you go
first i would say the late steve jobs is
someone i admired quite a bit
even though people kind of disagreed
with maybe his personality or things
about his decisions
one reason i think he was an effective
communicator is um that he knew the
court his core values and his company's
core values really well
and could motivate people based on them
the book has a link to his youtube video
when he came back to apple um after he
was originally fired and a lot of people
don't remember because it's the most
valuable company in the us now but
it was a very crappy company for a long
time after jobs left the company was
basically going down the toilet and this
was also during the dot-com boom kind of
before it where a lot of people had a
lot of good job offers and could have
left apple
and i really encourage people to watch
this video to kind of see what great
communication around values and core
values is
and he explained what is the core value
of apple we are not in the business of
making boxes to help people get their
work done
we are in the business of enabling
disruptors to change the world and he
said basically encapsulated apple's core
value is this which is martin luther
king and amelia earhart never had a
computer but if they had one you know
they would have used a mac
and that's just brilliant when you
really think about it and it really
explains what apple's customer base
likes to believe about themselves
and what the employees at apple like to
believe about themselves and so i think
you know just to kind of sum up is that
you know what he wasn't communicating
good communicator because he was a good
speaker he was a good communicator
because he understood his values and was
able to explain them very clearly with
like a simple phrase like that i love it
and and we also use that speech in the
strategic communication class i teach so
i'm very familiar with it and i do
encourage everybody to look at it
so ken uh who is a communicator that you
admire and why
communicators who i really admire
are great elementary school teachers
uh-huh
and it's because they do things i mean
they have a challenging audience to work
with like we think we have a challenging
audience teaching mba it's nothing
it is nothing compared to what an
elementary school teacher is dealing
with a great elementary school teacher
they know their audience they know how
to treat them respectfully but they also
know what they know in the audience
doesn't know so they know how to
simplify and releasely simplify their
core message to get across the stuff the
audience really needs and to tell this
is a story
and make it vivid to to the students and
i'm just in awe of the skill it takes to
do this i mean this is an incredible
craft i'm just blown away you know i've
spent a fair bit of time my daughter's
now 13. i spent a fair bit of time
volunteering in her schools over the
years and i think back on it it's like
that's really impressive communication i
wholeheartedly agree i think anybody who
teaches anyone where guilt and shame
doesn't work as a way of helping
moderate behavior it deserves
an award and you know as somebody who
studies communication anxiety and has
worked a lot on my own and helped others
i have never been more nervous than when
i was in one of my son's kindergarten
classes and the teacher had to step out
to take a phone call and i had 24
kindergarteners i have never been more
nervous in front of an audience before
so neil let me ask you the third
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe
so that was a really tough question and
i tried to take your metaphor a little
bit literally and thought about what is
the best food that has three ingredients
and i would say a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich is maybe i think the best
food that'll only have three ingredients
i agree you know so i thought about like
the peanut butter would be like one
knowing yourself and that's kind of a
big theme of our book which is to really
understand your own values not think of
them vaguely but to write them down to
revisit them to think about them to be
open to persuasion and to the jelly i
would say is empathy which is even it's
important to both know yourself and
understand others
at the same time and how their values
might be different from yours and then
the bread is really what makes the
peanut butter and jelly touch together
you know for the combination which is
this balance between being true to your
own values understanding others
persuading them using their stories not
yours but also being open to persuasion
yourself wow i i've never had anybody
literally take the ask of this question
and turn it into something so so the
response pbnj i think is is fantastic
well ken and neal thank you you have
provided us with so many insightful tips
and guidance that will help us to be
better more ethical leaders and
communicators
thank you so much and finally good luck
with your new book leading with values
strategies for making ethical decisions
in business and life i personally took a
lot of value from it and i know
everybody who reads it will be better
off and make better decisions in the
future thank you both
thanks for the great conversation thank
you matt it's been a great it's been
great to have a chance to talk to you
[Music]
thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from stanford graduate school of
business
this episode was produced by jenny luna
michael riley and me matt abrahams for
more information and episodes visit
gsb.stanford.edu or subscribe to our
show wherever you get your podcasts
finally find us on social media at
stanford gsb
[Music]
you